your turn Anthony okay first on CBS this
morning we are revealing the new Time
magazine cover
and while the magazine's had many iconic
covers the old King has been on him
this is a first despite appearances this
is not a photograph of Martin Luther
King jr. it is a new image created using
virtual reality an actor stood in for
dr. King and then a visual effects team
rendered that shard shot it is part of a
new project called the March which will
give people a chance to experience 1963
march on Washington as if they were
there it was made in collaboration with
a DuSable museum of african-american
history in Chicago I'm gonna be there
next week ahead of the exhibits opening
to talk with Viola Davis and her husband
Julius tennen they're the co-executive
producers of the project I am so excited
yeah they say this is the most realistic
digital rendering of a human ever
created and you're basically gonna be
there in the middle of that crowd of
250,000 people on the mall in Washington
at the March and that's great that viola
and Julius are involved they exactly can
imagine what its gonna feel like but
it's they've worked a long time in this
it's really exciting it solves a big
issue because people from that
generation memories are fading
yodeler dying people are moving on and
for Holocaust Remembrance and civil
rights era remember it could be a big
breakthrough Time magazine I have to say
is so creative and so clever in the in
how they do their covers some of the
best out there I think on the newsstand